[MUSIC PLAYING]
RUCHI BEZOLES: Good
morning, everybody.
I'm Ruchi, and this is Ben.
And we are from the
Google Photos team.
BEN GREENWOOD: We
built Google Photos
to help people
solve the problems
they were having
storing, organizing,
and sharing their memories.
And now, three years in,
we're delighted that hundreds
of millions of people
around the world
call the product home for
their photos and videos.
Here at I/O, we're
announcing a new way for you,
as developers, to be
able to use this platform
to build photo and video
experiences that are smarter,
faster, and easier to use.
In the session
today, we're going
to dive into some of
those new technologies
and show how you can use them to
bring the best of Google Photos
into your own apps.
Now, we designed
Google Photos and we
built the app for the way people
use photos and videos today.
This means users get
unlimited storage,
so, yes, we can
do the inevitable
and take 15 photos to
capture the perfect sunset,
or automatic backup, so we
never lose our memories,
even as we change
devices over time.
And of course, we've
built the product
with machine
learning at its core.
And you heard Sundar
speak yesterday
in the keynote about
the ways in which we're
applying AI to help
people organize and bring
their memories to life.
And one of my favorites that
the team's been working on
is what we call Color Pop.
What this means is the
Google Photos Assistant
can help you automatically
create images like this.
And you can see how
this effect really
elevates the subject in vivid
color, fading the background.
And if you look closely,
the AI has even identified
and segmented the flower
that this little girl
has in her hair.
It's pretty neat.
Now, these are just
a few examples.
But of course, we all
use our photos and videos
in different ways.
When we look across the
apps and devices that
are important to
people, we see a lot
of workflows that are difficult
and tedious, like if you've
ever tried to set up
a digital photo frame
and you're moving
files between devices.
It's a real chore just
to keep up to date.
Or how after you go
on a holiday trip,
your family memories
are handed to you
on a USB drive or even a DVD.
Like, what do I
even do with that?
And we're all constantly
downloading and re-uploading
content between services.
Maybe you're posting about
your latest adventures,
and you have some
awesome drone footage
that you want to include.
But it's in 4K, and
you have to download
and re-upload over mobile data.
And so we think it should
be much easier for people
to seamlessly use
their photos and videos
across all the apps and devices
that are important to them.
But to solve these problems,
we can't do it alone.
And that's why, today, we're
announcing the Google Photos
partner program and
giving you, as developers,
the tools and the
APIs you need to build
amazing photo and video
experiences for your users.
Now, as a developer, we know you
want to make your apps engaging
and user friendly.
And look, photos are a
great way to do that.
But often, this involves
complex infrastructure
for serving and having
to pay for storage just
to duplicate the
user's own content.
So we think that
should be easier, too.
And so at the core of
the partner program
is what we call the
Google Photos Library API.
This makes available some of
our best technology to you
to be able to bring the
best of Google Photos and AI
to help solve real
problems for your users.
And here's Ruchi
to tell you more.
RUCHI BEZOLES: Thank you, Ben.
All right.
Now, I'm going to
show you how you
can use the API to build
more engaging experiences
for your users.
There are three
main functionalities
that the API enables.
The first is that it
will allow your users
to access their library of
photos in your products.
The second is that you will
be able to upload photos
to a user's Google
Photos library.
And third, it will
provide the infrastructure
you need to enable sharing
of photos within your apps.
It goes without
saying, but all of this
requires explicit user consent.
So let's hone in on connect.
One of the main things we wanted
to solve when building this API
is to make it incredibly
simple for users
to access and experience their
photos in their favorite apps
and devices, many
of which you build.
This could be in Timehop,
where once you've
integrated your library and
given permission to use it,
you'll get more personalized and
creative reminders of memories
to look back on,
or on HP Sprocket.
It's a really cute,
portable printer
that will let you print
photos from your own library
as stickers on the go.
While this functionality
is fantastic,
to provide your users access to
their library in your products,
we also want to help developers
surface the right photos
a user might need in context.
And you can do this thanks
to the filters functionality.
There are four ways you can
filter a library of photos.
The first is content
categories, and that's
categories of photos
that a user has,
whether it's pet photos,
selfies, landscape photos,
landmark photos, so on.
Then there's the date of
when the photos were created,
so the time period
of photos and videos.
And then there's the date--
then there's the
media type, excuse me.
So that's whether it's a photo
or a video or something else.
You can pull those out, too.
And finally, a
personal album a user
already has created
in their account.
OK.
Time for a question.
How many of you here have
ever had to do expenses?
Raise your hands.
OK, full room.
Keep them up.
How many of you would say that
you have loved doing expenses?
OK, sad state.
Yeah.
Nobody really likes
doing expenses.
Neither do I.
But Xero, an app that
helps us do expenses,
is now integrating
with the Library API.
So what this means is they
can apply these filters
I referenced earlier, and
they can pull receipt images
in a certain time range and
surface them as suggestions
of expenses I should do.
So completing expenses
is as simple as viewing
the suggestion and
hitting Tab to submit.
BEN GREENWOOD: Pretty amazing.
Thanks, Ruchi.
RUCHI BEZOLES: Yeah.
BEN GREENWOOD: So using
these smart filters
is a really powerful
way that you
can make it easier
for your users
to find just the content
they're looking for.
And I'm going to show
you a few code examples.
And as the library
API is a RESTful API,
you can play along whether you
are a mobile, back end, or web
developer.
The first category--
or the first filter,
excuse me, that we
were most excited about
are content categories.
And as Ruchi mentioned, these
use Google's computer vision
to figure out what
an image is about
so you can filter and narrow
down results in your app.
The API offers many
categories to choose from.
And as you can see
from this example,
I can also exclude
categories that might not
make sense for my use case.
For example, an
app like Timehop,
which is there to really remind
me of my fondest memories,
may not want to include pictures
of old bills and receipts
and other documents
from years ago.
And filters are
a great way to be
able to exclude this content.
Another way that users explore
their content is based on time.
And sometimes, you'll want to
present photos chronologically
so you can scroll back in time.
But there are other
use cases where
being able to just jump
to the right moment
can make it much easier for your
users to find their content.
As you can see, you can filter
by specific dates or date
ranges, and you can also
combine filters together
to be even more expressive.
Say I wanted to find all of my
birthday photos from years past
and put them together
in a collage.
I could sit there and scroll
through decades of photos
to try and find
just the right pics,
or I could combine a
date and content category
filter like this.
You can see how we've
emitted the year here
and left it as a
wildcard so it'll
match any days on my birthday
and included a content category
filter to find those
great selfies and birthday
celebration moments.
It's pretty neat.
Of course, you can also
filter by other kinds
of media types,
so photos, videos,
or other kinds of
content, like VR.
And you can select photos
that are already in an album
that a user has curated
for some purpose.
But regardless of
the filters you use,
you'll get back a list of what
we refer to as media items.
And here's what one looks like.
Google Photos supports a wide
variety of media formats,
from the obvious photos
and videos to animations
and even complex VR
and 360 degree images.
So for each media item, you'll
get back this consistent JSON
object.
And there are a couple of
interesting attributes here.
The first is the
base URL, and this
is what your application
uses to access
the image bytes themselves so
you can show them in your app.
A subtle but really
powerful feature of this URL
is that it has
built-in resizing.
So with a simple
parameter, you can
ask Google Photos to return an
image that fits the dimensions
or aspect ratio for
your device, saving you
a lot of boilerplate code.
It also makes it really
easy to reduce data
transfer for users on mobile.
The second URL here
is a product URL.
And what this is is a deep
link back into Google Photos.
This can be really
helpful if you
want to provide a complete
and comprehensive UX
with common tasks like cropping,
rotating, and even viewing
complicated formats, such as VR.
You can just link
out to Google Photos
rather than rebuilding all
of that code in your own app.
And then, of course,
there's other metadata,
depending on the media
format you're dealing with.
And what's powerful
about this is
Google Photos will extract
this from a variety of media
formats, so you don't have to go
through and parse it yourself.
You'll have it returned in
this consistent JSON object.
And so with all of
this data together,
you're able to build and
include the user's content
inside of your user experience
and make it seamless and fast
for them to bring photos and
videos into your application,
just like the examples
we showed earlier.
RUCHI BEZOLES: Thank you, Ben.
All right.
So Ben talked about how users
can access their library
of photos in your products.
Now, what about when you need
to send users their photos?
The upload functionality
can help you do this.
So with the Library
API, developers
will be able to send
full-resolution photos
and videos to a user by adding
a directory into their Google
Photos account.
Let me walk you through
how this would work.
So this is actually
one of my photo albums
that I have at home, but
accessing all my albums
can be extremely
difficult. They're
buried in dusty
cupboards in my house,
or they are thousands of miles
away at my parent's home.
They live in
Germany, so it's not
going to be very frequent
when I get to see them.
But I decided to get this fixed.
I gathered my albums and
sent them to Legacy Republic.
They specialize in digitizing
physical albums and old media
formats, like VHS tapes.
I hope people have heard
about VHS tapes in the room.
OK.
So once they had digitized
it and it was ready,
Legacy Republic was able
to use the Library API,
create an album, and upload
more than 600 photos they just
digitized into my
account almost instantly.
That means at the
end of the day,
I had access to all of
my childhood memories
and some embarrassing photos
that I won't pull up here.
But they were all in
the palm of my hands,
right in the Google Photos app.
One thing my physical
albums do have,
and this is a scrapbook that
I had from when I was younger,
is a rich amount of information.
They don't just hold photos,
but they tell stories, at least
for me.
I scribbled little descriptions
of things I would think of,
the places where the
photos were taken,
or when they were captured.
With the Library
API, Legacy Republic
was able to take
this information
and bring it into a digital
album in Google Photos.
So a scrapbook like what
you saw turned into this.
So having hundreds of photos
in one place is really great,
but we also want to help users
find that exact photo they're
talking about in a story.
And thanks to the machine
intelligence in Google Photos,
we can do that, too.
So let's say I want
to show you my photos
from the last few weeks.
I'll just type in "me"
in the search bar,
and I'll get photos of me.
You don't look that impressed.
I guess, yes, those photos
are in the top of my grid,
so doesn't seem as hard.
But let's say I wanted to
tell you I was a little chubby
toddler when I was a baby.
I won't tell you
how many years ago,
but the next example will
tell it to you anyway.
I could type in "me in 1990"
and, in less than a second,
get photos of me as a baby.
So I think, Ben,
it's time for you
to show some of your
embarrassing photos.
BEN GREENWOOD: I don't
think anyone wants to see
those, Ruchi.
Now, I'm going to
show you how we
can create our own rich
albums using the API.
But before we do
that, a quick poll.
How many of you out
there have a friend
who's an outdoors person?
Go ahead and raise your hand.
You know, the type to go
camping and running and hiking.
And you'll know they're an
outdoors person, because they
will absolutely tell you about
it at every waking moment.
You'll come back into the
office on Monday morning,
and they'll regale
to you the epic miles
they covered and cliffs
and snakes and bears
that they had to fight with just
to get in for Monday morning
standups.
I have a confession to make.
In my team, that guy is me.
And so to prove this
to my colleagues,
a few months ago,
I went for a hike
in central Outback Australia.
It was a pretty memorable
trip, so I built a little app
to track my progress and take
a few notes along the way.
And now, we're going to try and
save it all in Google Photos.
So the first thing
we'll do with the API
is go ahead and create an album.
Simply send a POST request--
excuse me-- and you can
specify the title of the album.
And in the response,
you'll get back
an ID, which we'll
use in just a second,
and a product URL,
which is, again,
a deep link so you can show
the content in Google Photos.
As you can see, the
album's empty for now.
So let's fix that.
Second step is to
upload the actual image
bytes to Google servers.
Because we support a wide
variety of media formats,
you typically won't need
to worry about transcoding
between formats.
You just upload the bytes, and
the service will give you back
an upload token.
And we'll use it here in
the Create Media Item call,
as you can see.
We'll also fill in the album
ID that we just created.
And at this point, you're
probably thinking, OK, thanks,
Ben.
We've talked a lot,
done a lot of plumbing,
moved some IDs around.
How about you show me
something interesting?
Well, a big benefit of Google
Photos is being able to search
by what you remember.
Some of this happens
automatically, thanks to AI.
So I could search
for the Eiffel Tower
and find pictures I've
taken of the Eiffel Tower.
But there are some things that
only you or your app knows.
In this case, I'm taking
a photo of an area
my friends told me to go and
look at called "the pound."
And it's colloquial.
It's not on the maps,
so only I remember it.
But I can put it
in the description
with a few extra
details, and you'll
see that this, then, becomes
searchable in Google Photos.
And all that context is
stored right with the image,
so I can see it again
in years to come.
This is a great tool you
can use in your apps.
Maybe you're building
a game, and you
want players to be able to
save their favorite moments
and include the player's
name or the level
that their character was at.
Or maybe you're just delivering
marathon finish line photos
and want to be able to remind
the user of the great time they
got.
But let's be honest,
individual photos
aren't all that
interesting on their own.
So through the power of this
clicker, we'll add a few more.
Now, we mentioned
earlier that you
can create rich
albums that contain
text headings, locations, maps,
and even control the album
layout.
And in Google
Photos, we call these
features album enrichments.
Because there's not a whole
lot else to do in the desert,
each day I took a few
notes about the track.
And now, using
album enrichments,
I can group together my photos
to tell a meaningful story.
To do this, we'll go ahead
and call Add Enrichment
and create a text enrichment.
And finally, specifying the
position for the enrichment
to be displayed in the album,
maybe after the last photo
I took each day.
And as you can see, this
creates headings and dividers,
and our album's really
starting to come together now.
There are other kinds of
enrichments you can add, too.
I could add individual
locations or even
maps that describe the journey.
And this can be useful for
all sorts of applications.
Maybe you're an
amusement park, and you
want to be able to deliver
photos from the rides
that someone's just
taken in the park.
Or maybe you're just
trying to document
the progress of a project,
like building your first home
or seeing your child's
art project progress
throughout the school term.
But for my hiking app,
the finished product
looks a little bit like this.
You can see it's nicely laid
out with all the context safely
stored in my Google
Photos library.
And hey, now I can
easily share it
with all of my friends and
colleagues back in the office.
RUCHI BEZOLES: Yeah, I
think we've seen too many
of Ben's hiking photos.
But Ben did cue up
the perfect segue
to talk about the
sharing capabilities
that the Library API offers.
Did any of you go to the
I/O block party last night?
So you may recall--
yes, I see some of you.
You may recall seeing
this arcade photo booth.
Now, the photo booth
was really fun.
But what Ben and I
were most excited about
was that it was integrated
with our Library API.
So what this meant is you
didn't have to fight over
who gets that one physical
copy of that token
from your photo booth.
Instead, an attendee would
get a one-time shared album
where they can gather
all their photos
and videos that have
just been captured right
on the device they're using.
And something to
note is the attendee
doesn't have to have the photo
booth app or Google Photos
to get this link.
You can also bring the
sharing functionality
and make it work inside
of your mobile apps.
So let's take a look.
Here's an app for a soccer club.
Players are discussing where
to meet up, sharing scores
from the latest games.
But to share photos today,
they have to close this app,
open another app,
and then invite
the same group to share photos.
This doesn't seem
that efficient.
And so with the Library
API, these players
will be able to
upload photos as they
happen in the same conversation,
so everything can finally
happen in your app.
Let's take a look at this code.
With shared albums,
you'll have the option
to turn on or off comments or
allow users to collaborate,
so add their own
photos into the album.
In the response, they'll
get a sharable URL.
These are deep links that
open to Google Photos
and work across any platform.
And you get back a share token.
This is what you
will use to invite
people to join the shared
album from within your app.
It's what I showed you
in the soccer example.
Now, you need to show your
album in your app, right?
And to do this, you
send a GET request.
And you'll get back a
list of shared albums
that a user has joined.
So I'll pause on this screen.
The list you also get will
show attributes, like the title
and cover photo, which you will
be able to build into your UI.
This sharing
functionality really
comes together in
this final use case
I'd like to walk you through.
But first, let me tell
you a little story.
A few years ago, I decided
to gift my grandfather
a digital photo frame.
I felt like a really good
granddaughter, and he loved it.
Grabbed a USB drive, put in
10 photos, and there it was.
But years later, as many
of you have experienced,
my poor grandpa is watching
the same 10 photos on rotation
over and over and over again.
Now, Nixplay, they create
beautiful digital photo frames,
and they're integrating
with the Library API
to hopefully help
me fix this issue.
Let me show you how it would
work in this context now.
To get started, we would
create a shared album
in the Nixplay app.
And they can do this,
because they're integrated
with the Library API.
You can also pick
an existing album
you have in Google Photos, but
let's go through a new album
creation flow.
So you can invite people,
your friends and family,
to collaborate in this album.
And then you can
select that album
to be the main one you want
displayed on the frame.
After that, it's simple.
As friends and family
add photos to that album,
they'll automatically be
displayed on the Nixplay frame
you have in your home.
So I did put this
to the test, and I
connected my grandfather's
Nixplay app to my shared album
that I already had with him.
I put photos in there
when I'm thinking of him
or missing him as
I travel the world
or just sitting at
home in San Francisco.
So once we connected it up,
as I decided to share photos
with my grandfather,
he has a front row seat
to these moments in his
home all the way in Delhi
without having to
do any extra work.
BEN GREENWOOD: Thanks, Ruchi.
So we've shown you
today three great ways
that you can use the Library
API to bring the magic of Google
Photos into your apps.
We showed how you can create
seamless connections that
allow users to bring their
content into your product
and service and use smart
filters to help them find
just what they're looking for.
We've talked about how you can
use the upload functionality
to create more mobile-friendly
ways of delivering content
to your users.
And finally, we
talked about how you
can build deep, engaging
sharing experiences right
into your apps.
We've also aimed to
take a lot of the hassle
out of building a
seamless UX with features
like automatic
thumbnailing and deep links
that allow you to focus on
what makes your app unique.
And all the APIs services
we've talked about today
are available right now in
Developer Preview, which
means you can activate the API
and start building right away.
You can head over to
developers.google.com/photos,
which has full documentation.
And we have samples on GitHub
to help you get started.
Now, we've been working with
some amazing early partners,
and the demos we've shown are
a preview of things to come.
But if you're inspired
by what you've seen,
you can also find a
link on our website
to express interest
in joining the partner
program for your own product.
Now, I do want to
point out that we
care very deeply
about the experience
that Google Photos users have.
And that's why every
company we work with
is expected to meet certain
app quality guidelines,
and we also have strict
privacy provisions
that govern how you can use the
data that users agree to share.
We take those rules
very seriously.
And so as your
app grows, you can
expect a few chickens
from time to time
with the Google Photos team.
Finally, we really value your
suggestions as developers.
And so as you start
to explore the API,
please get in touch through
our developer channels
and give us your feedback.
You can also come along to the
Photos Office Hours here at I/O
and meet with the team directly
to talk about your app.
But that's it for
this morning session.
We're really excited
about the road ahead
and look forward
to working with you
to develop great products
that work with Google Photos.
We've been Ben and Ruchi.
You've all been a
wonderful audience.
Thanks very much.
Have a great I/O.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]